[Music]
thank you so about two years ago today
I've tried first moved out to the u.s. I
went up to Tahoe with a group of GSB
classmates and the GSB really started
how immense carry on with a holiday but
when we were up there I remember walking
through the beautiful mountain air
overlooking the lake when suddenly the
silence and the birdsong was shattered
by someone shouting you are such an
[ __ ] you can't say that here I was a
little bit shocked
someone was shouting at me why because I
just said that I voted for brexit now
I'd say I felt pretty taken aback by
someone that I'd really only just met
who was from Boston and had really zero
affiliation with the UK at all getting
angry at me for how I voted in the
brexit referendum it made me realize
that brexit is a controversial topic and
inker and engenders a lot of negative
stereotypes and negative emotions and
this guy had made an assumption about me
that really was totally incorrect and
misconstrued why I voted for brexit and
so I want to use this opportunity today
to tell you about why I did vote for
brexit I voted for brexit because I want
Britain to be more open more global I'd
not voted for brexit because I want
Britain to close in on itself and I'm
worried that all the bright intelligent
people here at Stanford and across the
rest of the world will be scared about
going and living and working and
investing in the UK because of those
negative stereotypes about brexit I
think that brexit I look forward to a
post brexit Britain that's more open
more global and more inclusive than it
was before and I want you guys that will
be excited about that as well so let me
start off by by putting bu in an
American context in my mind the European
Union can be split into two parts a
political union and an economic Union so
if we apply this to the mayor
because if we apply an economic Union
imagine a Federation of all 23 countries
in the whole of the Americas from Canada
all the way through Argentina trade
would would be free and tariff free
Argentinian states could be enjoyed in
Anchorage
in the same way that the Alaskan all and
gas could be traded in Buenos Aires
people would also be able to move freely
traveling wherever they liked to live to
work to study without without
discrimination how many of you in this
room and I won't see some hands how many
of you in this room would vote for such
system in the Americas so a few of you
now think about the political union
under the political union we take we
take a new Parliament and pace it say in
Peru and this would supersede the US
House and Senate and we'd start to make
the majority the rules that govern the
u.s. now for the Americans of you in the
room I'm sure you you'll love and you
will respect the Supreme Court but we're
going to replace that as well we're
going to put a new Court say in Belize
and this Court is going to be staffed
with judges from across the Americas and
we'll make the majority of the legal
decisions the matter to the United
States now how many of you would vote
for that system so I don't see any hands
and that for me is what the European
Union is is about now people in this
room I'm sure you like Mexicans you like
the Canadians especially if they look
like Justin Trudeau or or Rachel McAdams
but you do not want the good people of
Ottawa to be telling you what to do you
don't want the good people of Ottawa to
be telling you how many hours you should
be allowed to work in a given day
whether your prisoners should be allowed
to vote or not and most bizarrely of all
the size and shape that you're bananas
should be that those are all things that
the EU does and so for me Britain that
leaving the European Union is about
leaving that political union taking back
those decisions to the UK it's not about
leaving the Economic Union I think
leaving the
Konoe McGee nyan of the European Union
would be bad for both Britain and for
the rest of the world is it's good it's
going to make people poorer if Germans
can't sell their cars into the UK and we
can't sell our Scots Scotch whisky into
the rest of Europe but by leaving the
political union I hope that we can
expand our trade beyond just the
European boundaries and embrace more
global trade at the moment
global trade deals have to be negotiated
at a European level Britain is not free
to go and negotiate trade deals on its
own and that results in complications
within Europe there's lots of different
countries with lots of different
economies and different motives and
interests and those trade deals as a
consequence take a long time to
negotiate the most recent one was with
Canada and that took seven years for the
European Union to negotiate that deal my
hope is that Britain can embrace the
trading networks that we historically
had Britain has a great Commonwealth and
for a long time traded around the world
in the in the 1960s and 70s when Britain
first applied to join the European
Economic Community which is the
precursor of the EU it was actually
vetoed us joining was vetoed by the
French and the French reason was
precisely because they believe that
Britain's trading networks were too to
far-flung distant and diverse lands so I
believe that by leaving the European
Union Britain can reimburse and
re-establish those historical trading
networks embracing the world not closing
in on itself now embracing the world
does not just mean economically it also
means embracing the world's people when
I moved to the US two years ago it was
the first experience I'd ever had of
being an immigrant to another country
and I realized quickly how difficult and
how many difficult decisions you end up
being forced to make when you move to
somewhere else the hardest one for me
was involved my girlfriend at the time
called Sophie now Sophie and I had gone
out for for two and a half years and I
loved her very much
but when I got the phone call from Derek
to say that I got into Stanford the six
months following that the elation the of
getting into Stanford and coming and
living in California and meeting all
your amazing people that that elation
slowly turned to despair as we realized
that the u.s. visa rules meant it be
almost impossible for Sophie to move out
with me now I ended up obviously coming
and Sophie stayed behind and
unfortunately the the 12-hour flight and
the eight hour time difference was too
much for our relationship to bear but it
struck me as being incredibly unfair
that bright young ambitious people could
not come and work in the US and could
not come and contribute to the economy
here but unfortunately the same is true
of the UK and for Americans wanting to
go and work and live in the UK you would
find it extremely difficult as when
Britain is part of Europe to go and go
and move and work there and the reason
is is that you'd be behind the queue of
people from Poland from France from
Italy the are all entitled to come and
work and live in the UK by having open
borders to the whole of Europe you build
walls for the rest of the world and I
want those walls to come down Britain
should be open to accepting the bends
and sofie's of China of USA of India of
Africa and accepting as many bright and
brilliant people as we can we should not
just be restricted to the been Herman's
born Germans and benzino's of Europe so
for me opening up to the world is really
what brexit is about it's not about
closing in and if I go back to that time
in in Tahoe I wish I hadn't been so
taken aback there are fundamental
misconceptions and stereotypes are
applied to people that voted for brexit
but brexit is going to happen and it's
time that people that vote for brexit
stop feeling demonized for the way they
voted and start coming out and
presenting a positive vision for brexit
and for post brexit Britain for my part
brexit for me was about opening britain
up to the world not closing us in i'm
excited about the future of post brexit
britain as a hub of globalization
accepting brilliant people from around
the world and i hope some of you will
come join us thank you
[Applause]
[Music]